foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
fella
foreign
[Music]
long time right it's been a while been a
while
I mean it sort of has like if you only
watch us on YouTube then we missed last
week
but if you follow us on Twitch and
everywhere else then
we just did a seven hour stream today
which was not intended let me tell you
I was not intended
I mean this the stream was intended
we just didn't intend to go seven hours
as I'm as I'm learning the more we do
this it's just man once you get on a
roll dude it's just like it's so easy to
keep going so yeah I think I originally
thought okay we'll do three maybe a four
hour stream today
and then another stream tonight to top
it all off because we don't want to
upset our YouTube folks as well a lot of
you go back and forth some people just
like YouTube some people just like
twitch
so yeah
but um for anybody who may be dropping
in We're not gonna be doing any like
spoilers or anything tonight we will be
talking about the game and some news
around the game but no spoilers or
anything so
Elwyn with the five months that like it
blows my mind that it's only been five
minutes
how are you
blows my mind that it's only been five
months Owen like that this
whole thing has been happening right
five months feels like so much longer
welcome thank you for the five months
and also L when getting things started
with the five gifted
oh my goodness Elwyn how are you just
like she did today over on Twitch
which we are getting uh very close to
100 in the game guys very very close
welcome to
come thank you all so much for the five
gifted right there L1 congrats to those
of you who got one of the gifted
dude you know what I'm gonna go ahead
and mute this music because I don't know
if you guys saw what they posted today
on the official Hogwarts Legacy Channel
oh man I don't know if we're allowed to
play it though
I mean if it's all from the game
we should probably be good
how are you welcome to Griffin all right
we'll try it if you guys watch this
later if you guys are watching this on
replay Squad and the audio goes out for
a while
then you'll know why it's because of
copyright I think we're good with the
with the game soundtrack though
think we're good
[Music]
how are you welcome to anything we've
played from the actual soundtrack has
been totally fine yeah I know this one
for sure is good I know this one is I
don't know and I guess if it's all this
is played in the game which yeah I think
we're good but you never know for sure
with this kind of with the music stuff
all right and then right after Elwyn
Let's see we had Dustin Dustin what's up
dude Dustin in the house tonight gifting
out five gifteds as well
Jake with the six months
Jake and Dustin thank you so much let's
see who got those five gifted from
Dustin
who got the five gifted from Dustin
we've got zodiac Todd Tyler Nathan
Senate Murphy Aslan and Nick Shaw
congrats
on the gift of memberships guys
[Music]
congrats congrats congrats
there's another sub right there a couple
more subscribers welcome in guys welcome
in
oh man this like this stream like I feel
like the pressure's off I don't have to
uh
we're not doing any gameplay stuff so we
can just chill and hang out
and there's a lot to talk about I know
it's kind of crazy right we thought the
game would come out and then the news
would be gone how are you no welcome to
Gryffindor nope
a lot more news
how are you welcome zootara zootar with
the five gifteds as well zutara thank
you so much how have you been zachari
did you beat the game oh how are you
because I'm pretty sure was it a comment
it was either a comment on a YouTube
video or it was the
maybe in our last live stream
where I saw a comment from you saying
you were you were trying to avoid
spoilers and everything so
[Music]
how are you welcome to Gryffindor
oh yeah Jake you got the gold now yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
what's it like not having a job being on
YouTube instead of
instead
I don't know what you meant after that
you're the best
yeah I mean it's great it's like it's
been crazy so far because we haven't
really
[Music]
it's been wild around my house with sick
kids we've had we've had a lot going on
with the kids being sick and my wife and
I were sick I had a really crazy eye
infection in fact I think two weeks ago
when we streamed I didn't do webcam
because yeah this whole lie was just
looked like I'd been in a boxing fight
or something
yeah congrats to those who just got one
of the gifteds
all right let's see who all we got in
the house tonight
man this audio is really loud
I'm gonna turn it
to like right there
just a little subtle background right
now all right let's see who do we have
here we got Alicia
Antoine hey I saw you in the chat too do
grimly David was here Dr sherbet
Dustin Quist Elwyn feathers how's it
going feathers Gavin we got Jake Jason
Jenny
l-o-l-o dot in matt88 new store
see a couple names from uh from twitch
this morning as well Ryan Kingsbury in
the house what's up Ryan member of House
rack and tour uh Terrell Sims the
sisters
Tyler Bennett Willow Kaiser zigster
zodiac zutara babe everybody there in
the house thank you all for being here
and hanging out dude we we're gonna
start off with a bang
you guys saw my tweet or if you saw my
post on YouTube I was trying to trying
to get people a little bit time to get
here because
I think you guys are gonna enjoy this
one I think you're gonna enjoy this one
and while part of it may be what you
think
I think there's gonna be a surprise too
so WB uh first off reached out a couple
weeks ago and asked if we would like a
collector's edition and I said why sure
I would love one thank you very much for
considering us
however I believe there are some
additional items in here as well so I'm
expecting a collector's edition I took a
little peek and just confirmed like okay
that's what this is
but there is more than a Collector's
Edition in here so first off it is a
massive massive box let me try to figure
out what's going we you I mean look at
that I didn't even know it was in the
frame of the camera right there you can
already see it here so I'm just gonna
move the mic back for a second
just so you guys
you guys War box
let's see if we can even get it all in
the frame I'm gonna have to completely
okay wait right there there we go
there we go all in the frame right there
all right so
be careful to make sure I don't show my
address here
all right so now fragile Handle With
Care
so on top
we have this right here which at first I
thought oh this is the collector's
edition
that's what I thought at first however
it's not
so we have this box here something
something in here
set that to the side for now
then this one is more recognizable
here we have a copy of the Collector's
Edition on the PlayStation 5. Now
for those of you who have been really
following oh my gosh it's the God of War
thing all over again I don't have enough
room here we've got a
let's get this box out of the way
for those of you been following
everything we've said so I got a
collector's edition
from GameStop
and I told you guys if something works
out I will most likely be giving that
away I just didn't know if this was
going to work out yet so that one has
sat up here unopened I haven't even used
my Kelpie robe or anything because the
the wb1 were not allowed to we can't
give that one away so keeping this one
for myself for sure
so I haven't even opened it I have not
even seen the collector's edition yet
haven't unlocked my Kelpie robe haven't
done any of that so we're about to do it
right here right now so I'm gonna set
this the mystery I mean look at that it
is
it is pretty thick it's almost as big as
the collector's edition so we're gonna
sit that to the side
tease the you know the excitement here
all right and then we have the PS5
collectors
right here we go so we go ahead and
slide this off
and let's see on the back you have live
the unwritten so yeah steel case and the
full game for PS5 I'm curious to see if
it comes with the regular case and the
steel case so when Chandler did the
unboxing it was only the steel case but
they've always showed it with that box
as well then you have the floating wand
with the book that's the big attraction
the box of course the dark arts pack and
then the Kelpie rope dark arts Garrison
hat as well
all right so
I'm really curious to see this this wand
the ancient magic wand
they didn't they didn't do that one here
Willow
are you talking about uh are you UK or
us because I know a lot of times that
varies based on territory like I have
the uh Metroid dread collectors edition
almost said Metroid Prime I can't find
Metroid Prime dude it's crazy how the
Metroid Prime remastered it's sold out
everywhere
and I know there's a digital copy as
well but man I want the physical
I'm gonna keep looking but
yes it does come with the Box let's go
dude I was really hoping that it would
because as much you know I think steel
books are cool
all right so that is for
let's see this is for the oh the Kelpie
robe let's go dark arts Garrison hat and
kelpy robe
all right and then that's the box there
all right so a copy of the Hogwarts
Legacy
Deluxe
it's my first time actually holding a
game box it's my first time holding the
Hogwarts Legacy game box dude let's go
very cool I'm glad it came with that
well you know what see we could use this
uh
let me see if I can zoom out here
that we can get a little bit more in the
frame
all right so okay that's opposite we
want to zoom out there we go
there we go
oh yeah and then this other thing so
this came with my GameStop copy
they did not advertise for some reason I
don't know why they like they should
have advertised that was going to be
included
this came it's like a little uh
like a little metallic
little tin that you could hang up
somewhere pretty cool though so yeah I'm
still in the process of organizing this
shelf here and I've been waiting I knew
this was going man because I want to see
oh my gosh the book I really want to see
if I can fit the book up here somewhere
because that would be epic I don't think
I'm gonna be able to but
I think we can for sure get this did
they advertise it I never saw anything
about it and I pre-ordered a GameStop
months ago
here probably a year ago they never said
anything about like hey it's going to
include this too
I actually heard from several people who
said yeah I had no idea and then it just
uh it just happened
just months after oh really like months
after all right so there okay that is
nice that is a nice steel case I gotta
say
gotta say that will look very nice on
the Shelf here
very nice on the Shelf
you have like the uh
Hogwarts crest on the front with the
never tickle a sleeping Dragon see if we
can hold that up a little bit closer so
you guys can
do you see yourself in the reflection
look at you guys
they're all of you are
man with the light you can't even really
tell what it is that's all right we'll
figure that out later
we will figure that part of it out later
but I really want like one of these
shelves
has got to be dedicated to either Potter
and or Hogwarts in some way
some way
all right so that's that and then
here is the first look
the floating wand
all right let's see so we got the little
cable right here oh wow this is all
this is all tied down very
gotta be careful here make sure we don't
break anything
the book is the main thing right we
don't want to drop the book
there we go okay so the book actually
it's like a separate piece here
it sounds a lot worse than it is I
promise
it's just tape it's just tape
all right there it is dude the ancient
Magic Book
oh wow
and then I guess this is like some
instructions on
oh yeah it's instructions on how to get
the wand to actually float
to to have the magic using the magnets
you know
yeah dreaming hey and dreaming thank you
so much for the uh
let's see renewing wait hold on what did
I'm Dreaming dreaming with the Super
Chat why did that not show up over there
it is there it is yo what's up good to
see another stream man hoping the best
for you and your family on the full-time
YouTube Journey dreaming appreciate it
dude
appreciate it appreciate the donation
appreciate the kind words but yeah guys
if you didn't see our announcement here
on YouTube this is uh
this is my job now this is officially
what we're doing
so obviously it won't just be limited to
Hogwarts Legacy in the long term but
yeah right now man it's it's all I would
say mostly about Hogwarts but we've been
streaming over on Twitch having a lot of
success there a lot of you've been
turning out to those gameplay streams
which has been awesome to see
and we're gonna keep talking gaming news
too so we were I was asking today on
YouTube like what kinds of videos are
you guys interested in but there's a
video up now on our YouTube channel
where I kind of outlined the plan of
everything that we're going to be
covering
all right so here's what we have you
have Hogwarts up here in the top left
you got the Black Lake
forbidden force over here hogsmead over
here
and then on the back you've got like
portkey games
the mysterious figure here
the mysterious figure the ancient magic
symbol which we all know and are
familiar with at this point let's hold
it a little bit closer there
so you guys can see it
there you go and then I mean just to
kind of compare it
size so you guys can get a like I felt
whenever I opened up this Hammer the
hammer is like huge so it is about
a little bit shorter than the hammer
or wider I guess
the Hammer's a little bit wider when you
stretch them across like this
so let's see dude let's see I don't
think it's gonna fit man but I really
hope it does
not gonna fit not gonna fit we'll have
to figure out another place for it yeah
so that is the base
and then let's get the wand out let's
check out the wand
it is crazy man how well the hammer was
just like the perfect fit
if the hammer was any bigger it would
not fit up there it would not fit if it
was any bigger at all
harder than I expected oh to get the
Wanda float did you get one two feathers
nice does the hammer float could you
imagine
if we if we tried the Hammer with it and
it actually managed to float too now I'm
sure the uh the wand has some kind of
magnets in there I would say
oh yeah so on the back here
we have these little uh
twisty ties we have to undo here
get the wand out
so yeah thanks again to our friends over
at WB for sending this to us
so we could unbox it here on the channel
let you guys get a good look at it and
then don't forget don't forget we still
have the mystery box
the mystery box we knew like the
collector's edition we knew about
the other stuff is a mystery
all right so there's the wand
don't worry I'm okay
piece of plastic fell
all right and then
we've got to get the power cable out as
well
gotta try it out dude we gotta plug it
in
and I think I should be able to adjust
the camera
so you guys can see it in action too
all right so there's that
oh come on oh there's one more last one
do I have Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone for GameCube
not sorcerer Stone on GameCube no no the
one the first time I ever played uh
sorcerer Stone it was on PC
Chamber of Secrets though I played on
the GameCube yeah
and then
Prisoner of Azkaban
yeah I have that one for GameCube
um Goblet of Fire I never owned
um then order the Phoenix was the Wii
but now I now I own it for PlayStation
3. that's the one we've been the version
we've been playing on stream whenever we
uh before Hogwarts Legacy came out
all right so you have the cable again
everybody talked about the cable like
how it's sort of you know it's white and
glaring you just I mean I think you'll
just have to find a place to kind of
tuck it away which should be easy enough
to do all right so right now I'm just
gonna plug it in right behind me
all right so we got that now let's plug
the book in
all right so you plug it in looks like
on the top side
right there is where the plug goes
see do I hear power emanating from it
no no it doesn't sound like any power
is there an on off switch or does it
just
yeah they did include instructions I
should probably look at those
I should probably look at the
instructions right
all right so let me just adjust this
here
and move the mic out of the way
and then watch this we should be able to
go
with our camera here
oh there we go
all right so let me turn it like this
oh nope not that way
maybe a little bit more
there we go
there we go all right
and we have the ancient magic wand
yeah somebody was asking so we're not
we're not really spoiling story stuff
but yeah this is the wand
that comes into play late in the game
late in the game right here it is oh my
goodness dude
that kind of freaked me out a little bit
man it just like instantly
hold it over there oh my goodness okay
it's like flipping it over wow okay I
feel
not expecting that I feel the magnet
right in there but right now is pulling
me opposite okay so wait do I need to
position it like this
all right all right I know instructions
there's a reason
there's a reason they were included
and hey who was it I think feather said
it was harder to get it to float than
you expected
all right so number two
okay oh it has like a very specific
point
all right so wait I'm working upside
down hold on we are working upside down
so okay it needs to be this way
gosh it is so
it's just like it's just snapping it
I mean are you are you supposed to keep
the paper on there though
I guess you can move the paper once you
get it
once you get it lined up
so yeah the paper has little arrows
where you can just line it up oh man
we're talking about ASMR earlier
how's that
how's that for a little ASMR chat
alright so yeah we need to go
oh yeah so this is like the sheet to
line it up right here
all right so Black Lake
Black Lake
all right there we go it's lined up
right there
Okay so
you know
Ash
dude
this is so crazy man
you can feel the power of it moving
no I want you to float
all right so it looks like I mean
definitely this is the right direction
the handle over here on this side
and then here's a little star right here
like there's where it's showing us the
star
it just keeps like
oh
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait
oh there it is dude
there it is
[Music]
you don't know the power of the dark
side
oh we got it oh wow it's pointing at me
now
pointing at me
I'm the chosen one yeah
now let's see okay hold on if it don't
anyone panic if it snaps into place
somewhere I'm gonna try and see can you
actually move the book
oh that's crazy you can
oh
no all right we're gonna slide it just
ever so slightly over here to the left
ever so slightly over
oh it's still on there though it's
locked in
dude that's crazy it's teetering back
and forth right now
teetering back and forth all right very
cool very cool
now the mystery box
the mystery box ladies and gentlemen
all right hold on we're gonna see this
let me take the camera back up a little
bit here
yeah right there right there
I might throw the AK I know all right so
if you guys are just tuning in we
received a special package from our
friends over at WB Games we open up the
collector's edition just now for PS5 now
there was another very large
mystery item inside
very large Okay so
all right it's like a giant piece of
foam here
I think it's supposed to open up like
this though
oh my goodness
wow look at that dude
okay so yes we have
the art book over here on this side
and then four house
hold on dude that's those are like
actual patches four house patches
hold on let me see if I can lift it out
of here I think I can
oh yes perfect
look at that dude
if you guys can get a little bit all
right where are the gryffindors at
Gryffindor
and then let's see our oh hold on the
mics in the way
ravenclaws where are you at ravenclaws
and then we have our slytherins
and then we have
Hufflepuff
somebody said they want the uh
they want the Hufflepuff one Dr sherbet
my wife's a Hufflepuff you know
my wife is a Hufflepuff
oh my gosh though hold on you guys these
might actually be able to
I mean you could take them out
like this is like a little foam backing
but I think I might want to just keep
them in here maybe hang this up
somewhere
like we could hang that oh you guys
can't see it hold on
we have some room above our
come on come on camera
you have some room above here
oh dude that's actually sick
that might look really good actually
wow okay that is very cool and then the
art book here
which many of you guys may have a copy
of this
the art and making of Hogwarts Legacy
again I haven't opened it haven't looked
at
anything in this art book yet other than
what you know the few things they showed
early I didn't even look at the leaks
like I read about the leaks and stuff
but
man okay that is too cool
too cool
so yeah
thank you guys thank you guys uh over at
WB for sending that man I'm gonna have
to find a good place for all of these
things man all of these
but but but what this also means for
everyone here is we
are going to be giving away
this collector's edition right up
right up here
with the golden snitch on top of it nope
not that way right there
right there that collectors edition
we're gonna be giving away so stay tuned
stay tuned to uh
our Twitter and our
YouTube Community page obviously Discord
as well and we will keep you posted but
yeah I'm I am definitely planning on
giving that away it's the PS5 version
American uh the US version of the game
so I don't know if that will
affect who can play it and who can't but
yeah so
that is too cool man too cool
yeah exactly Beantown exactly gonna be
giving it away I just want to make sure
um there's a website called I think it's
gleam.io I just need to set everything
up on there
and figure out exactly how we're gonna
let people enter and all that make sure
we give people plenty of time
and yeah man Pay It Forward pay it
forward that's that's
that's the goal
but I can't wait to put those patches up
somewhere
those patches are awesome
Too Cool Man Too Cool all right so I'll
wait to command stop working
oh yeah they don't we don't have all the
commands over here on YouTube
some of them work but yeah
I think what I need to decide is I'm
going to pick one bot for YouTube and
one bot for twitch
and then just set them all up
accordingly because right now we
basically have like three bots in both
uh
both twitch and YouTube
and so it just
just messes with things yeah Discord
works but Twitter yeah the twit I think
we have a Twitter one here
it's just I'm pretty much retro
racketour everywhere
retro raconteur across the board
all right so that's not what we want
[Music]
you guys didn't see this they just
posted the uh full
soundtrack today on the official
Hogwarts Legacy
YouTube
[Music]
all right so let's set up our
there we go
[Music]
yeah man what do you guys uh
I got a good pull I got a good pull I
want to see how many of you
let me move it over here
you guys can keep watching there
I want to see how many of you have
beaten Hogwarts Legacy yet
all right so your Channel
start a poll
have you beaten the story in Hogwarts
Legacy yet
question mark yes or no
somebody playing all four houses at once
Draco was saying that dude Draco I don't
know if draco's here tonight
he was over in the
twitch chat earlier
he's about to get his third 100 percent
playthrough
his third because I was like wait a
second you just played through twice and
now you're 100 on the third character no
100 on one house 100 on a second house
100 on a third house
blew my mind
how do you become a mod Jake
um just
honestly
we look for mods based on
interaction in chat how they interact
with other people in the community
how often they're present you know
if they represent the type of
values and stuff that we promote as a
channel
and then as as needed right so like
right now we're pretty we're pretty good
on mods but
yeah thank you for asking the mods are
always looking so like if we if there
ever comes a time when we realize hey we
need to add like a couple mods
we'll all ask the current mods you know
who have you guys been noticing in chat
that you feel like would make a good
moderator that's how we got Jenny and uh
Dr sherbet actually
Ginny AKA Damia one
and also Dr sherbet yeah
your only Antoine hold up hold up 15
hours in still need to go to astronomy
yes so yeah we beat the game uh on the
story not story difficulty the story
mode
not the story mode I can't talk too much
streaming in one day we already went
seven hours on Twitch now we're on
YouTube
we played through beat the story on
normal then we bumped it up to heart and
I kind of wish I'd had it on hard the
whole time but yeah now we've just been
going through over on Twitch trying to
100 everything
and we knocked out a lot today actually
so all I need to go I need to get all
the collections
that's all the little
items that you can get for the room of
requirement you have to get all those
open all the chests all that stuff and
also you have to get um
what's the other one all the Merlin
trials that's the big one as well
you have to get all the Merlin trials
done too
Jaybird you're already on your fourth
playthrough
Shay on on your third playthrough wow
GG what's up didn't listen to the
soundtrack yet hey that's what we got
playing right now
that is what we have playing
portero what's up dude welcome in
welcome in do you guys think the
replayability is good or is it too
repetitive so
I love like doing the the full
collecting and everything
but after that first playthrough I'll
probably play through again because I
want to do like Go full dark arts
but yeah I do wish they had more like a
new game plus that's what we were
talking about today on stream
if they added a new game plus because
right now I'm so overpowered at this
point which it's crazy it kind of
happened
and I'm even playing on hard mode it
happened when I started upgrading my
gear
which I hadn't really put much attention
into until I started getting closer to
level 40 and I was like okay let's
finally look into this and actually
upgrade a lot of this gear
and as soon as we did that man started
putting on some of those traits
we're just like
I mean really rocking through rocking
through enemies with not much trouble
Craig four created only one is finished
the main story yeah I only have one I
mean I made a second one as my wife just
because I needed to record some footage
of the Ollivander section but that's
really the only reason I did that one
AJ AJ with the Super Chat what is up my
friend taking my sweet time with the
game still have a long way to go to
finish the game uh get bored with the
Highland stuff can never get tired of
the Hogwarts stuff
I mean right take your time dude play it
how you want to play it when draco's
like I've already I'm on my third 100 if
you want to play that way go for it if
you're somebody who wants to take your
time and
you know play it over the course of
months why not right why not
a dark Hufflepuff
Joseph just got 100 let's go
feathers you struggling in the last few
revelio pages I I need to do that pretty
soon too but I'm they're all in Hogwarts
they're all in Hogwarts so I'm glad I at
least had them confined to one area
reaction assassin what's up dude yeah
man yeah yeah we made the jump
we made the jump
we did and you guys are a huge reason
for that everybody here watching right
now support all these live streams dude
it's been amazing
so yeah there's if you guys didn't see
we're officially full-time content
creator now
so we're obviously going to have a lot
more to come with Hogwarts Legacy stuff
but yeah we're going to start covering
other games as well
but man honestly like thinking about all
the Hogwarts Legacy content that's still
out there to be made
it may be a while before we get to
covering other games how I Envision so I
have a video up on the channel now kind
of explaining the move and letting you
guys know what's what's ahead but
this actually ties in perfectly let's
get into the news
let's get into the news because there
have been some major
[Music]
Hogwarts Legacy stories dropping
so we'll start with this one from
this is 11 days old so it's a little bit
it's a little bit old now
so this was from IGN Hogwarts Legacy
developer confirms there are no current
plans for DLC I think the headlines a
bit misleading
so they talk to game director Alan 2
during IGN Fan Fest Hogwarts like is a
game director Alan to explain that the
team was so busy preparing the game for
its launch last week that it hasn't yet
planned on releasing any expansions okay
well that's what IGN said now let's
listen to what Alan said we've been
really heads down bringing Hogwarts
Legacy to life said too so at the moment
at
the
moment
there are no current plans for DLC
that's not to say Avalanche will be
supporting the game post launch of
course as it has already released a
patch for the game that includes several
performance improvements and other
updates Hogwarts legacies already
received somewhat of an additional
Mission thanks to the PlayStation
exclusive Quest fans will just have to
wait and see if Avalanche software
announces any proper extras but given to
his comments it doesn't look likely
[Music]
I don't believe it
I don't believe it you guys
for a second
so look man I mean it's it's kind of a
weird launch right because they had to
stagger things you know they had to
stagger things they made a decision to
put the current gen versions out
when they could
push back PS4 Xbox One pushback switch
even further
so their priorities right now as some of
the developers some of the people
working at Avalanche have even said this
on Twitch or on Twitch on Twitter
they've talked about this you know like
their priority right now is for this
so of course they're not going to
announce any DLC right now right I mean
that would that would be
almost like I mean how would that make
you guys feel those of you who are
waiting on the old gen systems it's like
oh yeah we're
working on DLC and it's getting ready to
come out and the other guys are just
like
what are you are you gonna be are you
gonna get the game out for us so yeah I
mean
I think you look at what Alan said no
plans
hold on let me go back to it
uh at the moment
at the moment guys
like
if there's not DLC for this game I will
be incredibly surprised incredibly
surprised
and I'm talking like extensive DLC I
mean and people been who knows when
right I mean look at Eldon ring look at
Eldon ring just finally today
we finally got the announcement
that yes there's going to be DLC for
Elden ring which we all knew it would it
was going to happen we all knew it was
gonna happen it was just a matter of
when
they should add Merlin cloak as a reward
for completing all 95 Merlin trials
that's you know what that's actually a
really good idea I'm kind of surprised
that they didn't
maybe that was originally a plan and see
that's the other thing like who knows
what else they have planned we had no
idea about these switch drops like we
had no idea that was going to be a thing
and then either was it like the I think
it was after
it was like right there when they were
launching the game that's when it
happened
you're missing most of the revelio pages
in hogsmead
yeah GG it sounds amazing we're just
kind of listening to it here in the
background
they they absolutely knocked it out of
the park with the music they did
[Music]
Joseph yes I would love that
she didn't wanna
my wife just brought Luna back
she was trying to see if she would hang
out with her tonight
did she just jump up
[Music]
oh Luna she loves hanging out here with
me man
loves being with you guys what can I say
you're a wizard Harry oh that's too
funny my wife's like tonight I'm gonna
take her upstairs with me and see if
she'll just if she'll stay with me nope
she had to come back down
but yeah Joseph I agree I think it'd be
great if we could change seasons
yeah we could talk about that too man
that's probably going to be the next
video I'm working on is what are some
like quality of life updates we could
see that would benefit current players
and also players on PS4 Xbox One and
switch if they could get them in those
in time as well
not necessarily jump into DLC ID ideas
just yet because I have a lot but
yeah I would love if you could change
the seasons because they're so
just each one is so unique right and
then once you beat the game you're stuck
with one
as far as I know
David played an evil playthrough the
first one as a Slytherin now you're
playing as a good Ravenclaw
have that good saved life
he didn't say never exactly Ginny
Deek thinks you should be proud of you
do full time hey thank you AJ appreciate
it
right at the moment there are no current
plans
no current plans for DLC
which is what you'd expect him to say
you know
and to be honest Alan's not the one who
would announce it anyway right
there's a lot of other people that would
have to be involved in the announcement
of of such a thing
if they had DLC and he said yep it's
coming
they'd be like Alan no what are you
doing
don't say it
oh yeah Jenny you know it right
I mean the the way that this game has
landed in terms of the sales which
that's another news item
in terms of sales and also fan reception
I mean it's Avalanche is on the map now
right they are on the map as
and they're in a position they're in a
great spot right now they're gonna be in
a spot where they can really do
what they want to do I feel like if WB
will probably go to them be like hey
how about how about more how about more
Hogwarts stuff right
which if I can find it
like they've already told us man
they've already told us they want to do
more
oh this is Chandler okay wait but this
might be the one
foreign
that down just a bit
I mean we've talked about it here on
this show before
right there it is
with your continued support we hope to
explore even more in the future this was
months before the game came out when was
this this was uh
when was it March 17 2022. look at that
almost a year ago
and we all know what that means with
your support with your continued support
what that means is if the game sells
well if the fans like it if it sells
well well guess what guys
the game is selling well fans are loving
it
they want to explore more in the future
so there you go
so yeah I mean I think IGN's obviously
reporting on what he's what he said
see if they had anything else in here
foreign
this right here though this is the part
I disagree with
given two's comments it doesn't look
likely
nah
nah bro
no way
and then since that story hold on let me
catch up with Chad here catch up with
chat because then there's been an
additional story this one was February
22nd so just six days ago
just six days ago and hey degrimly
renewing their tier one thank you so
much to grimly good to see you here
hanging out
appreciate you
appreciate you my friend
that's another one Antoine yes photo
mode photo mode photo mode would a
thousand percent be on my list
oh did Eric write a tweet oh I did not
see that L one hold on hold on hold on
[Music]
let me pull that up here
let me see if I can find it
so that was February
not finding it
because wait when did IGM post that
17th
yeah I don't see any thing from Eric
maybe Chandler
I don't see anything from Eric on
Twitter
definitely make DLC the game is barely
yeah yeah yeah
it's barely out I mean look look how
long it took elderly to just do the
announcement
right
it's a good sign though that people are
already asking for wait we want more we
want more
can be at the game twice going through a
third time Samantha let's go
yeah David Luna totally has her routine
hey all good Jesse no worries no worries
Mrs rack into where they need to add
dogs what's with all the cats
I guess it's a wizard thing I don't know
I don't know
oh it was a different Eric it was not
Eric Martin it was a different Eric yeah
yeah yeah that's what I was alluding to
when I said Developers
when I said some of the developers it
was uh
yeah we could read that one on stream
here
[Music]
Twitter
I think it's Eric Brown
yeah Eric J Brown
which I'm not actually sure what his
role storytellect for Hogwarts Legacy I
actually re I think I retweeted this one
too
yeah I could probably find it faster if
I go to my page
[Music]
foreign
T there it is
oh yeah it was in uh
a tweet from Paul so Paul Tassie was
reporting on
the IGN story
of and Paul tassie's tweet said Hogwarts
Legacy has no plans for DLC which seems
like a mistake
this is Eric Brown
who uh works at Avalanche Story related
better way to frame Allen's response to
the DLC question is to remember that
we've only launched on half of our skus
so far so half of their
platforms basically there are people out
there who still don't have the game or a
game in their hands yet and we don't
want to shortchange those folks
exactly right
exactly it would just it would it would
be a weird
it'd be an awkward announcement right if
they announce if they said there's DLC
coming while they're still patching bugs
and glitches and people are still having
trophies that they can't unlock and
they're still platforms that they've
said they're releasing on that they
haven't released on yet so yeah
it all makes sense but I
totally would be
so incredibly shocked if DLC for this
game did not happen at some point
if you press the map button you
automatically open the map area where
you are instead of the open world
yeah I've seen a lot of interesting
ideas for alohomora
so one idea I read was that like when
you unlock
level one you do the mini game but then
when you unlock level two level one
locks open automatically
level two locks would require you to do
the minigame then you go up to level you
unlock level three then two and one
automatically open level three locks
would require you to do the mini game
still so you would only have to do the
ones on the mini game for level three
but then the other option I saw was
oh what was it like when you hit Mastery
you just unlock all of them which is
what you're saying there yeah when you
hit level three
[Music]
so yeah the biggest things I'd like to
see
and I'm I'm focusing on not like big
picture DLC stuff that would require a
lot more I'm focusing on like just
within the confines of the current game
uh photo mode we already talked about
that one for sure for sure for sure the
game's so gorgeous the sky boxes I mean
the the scenery the changing of the
seasons the the night day cycle
everything like it just looks so great
when you're flying around the world
photo mode for sure New Game Plus
New Game Plus now this one again I'm not
a developer I don't know what has to go
in on the back end like something to
scale up the difficulty
and let you play through again however I
don't know how they would do maybe you
still have to unlock the Spells as you
normally would because a lot of those
are Story related but then maybe like
all the traits and stuff you keep all
your Cosmetics all your gear you keep
that might be the best way to do it yeah
yeah
um
I also really wish there was a way to
redo
a lot of the mini games
so you can keep going for high scores on
the Broom
but like once you get done with
summoner's court that's it
that's it like you can't go back and
redo those I think that'd be fun to like
go for high scores see if you can
completely
if he could beat you know if you because
you can keep replaying the person as
many times as you want if you're losing
but then once you win
that's it
this music feels a little loud on my end
so turn it down just a bit
so yeah I'd like to see that's
um we said photo mode already we talked
about I think they could make some
changes with the day night cycle to
where it stays day a little bit longer I
don't know if this is true or not I
haven't timed it myself but there was a
big Reddit post about somebody actually
timed it
and it stays day for
a short amount of time then it's night
or at least like visually and I've
noticed something very strange whenever
you're trying to interact we were doing
the astronomy tables today
and you can only interact with those at
night same for the demigay statues and
there were a lot of times when it looked
night I mean you look up at the sky it
looks dark you see the stars and yet I
couldn't interact with a thing
so maybe if they added an in-game clock
or something so you could see if it's
early morning and when you skip ahead
time it should say whether you're going
from day to night or night to day vice
versa
but yeah then if there because if I
don't know why they would make Night
Longer though that just doesn't make
sense to me but I definitely like just
anecdotally like from a fee like from
just playing the game it feels dark way
more than it's light out so I don't I
don't know I don't have the actual data
behind it
the chess game added now see that's an
example of something that's like
I don't feel like that could come in a
patch or an update that's like a DLC
thing like a mini DLC
um the other thing I was gonna say is
like crossed ones
why does it just go away why can't we
replay those
that totally surprised me cross ones
ended
much faster than I expected it to end I
don't know about you guys like I thought
that was going to be a recurring thing
throughout the game like you were gonna
keep coming back and they're gonna be
harder tougher challenges
and then it was only a couple
so even if we could just replay the ones
we did I mean that'd be a way to like
work on combos
that sort of thing
but with that one and also with the uh
oh with the summoner's court like
this might get too far into the DLC area
but like imagine if they could increase
difficulty on them or give you like more
opponents
or if they can make it to where the AI
changes a little bit each time which I
notice with some characters I feel like
it did like they didn't do the same move
every time but then with others it was
like every time their first move was
always the same
yeah cross one was super fun I enjoyed
it I just thought it was uh I thought it
was going to be around for longer there
was going to be more to do
you were surprised by that too Jenny
yeah
in the fall and winter is it not normal
that days are shorter and nights longer
yeah I guess I would have to I don't
know how that Reddit post calculated
like if it was
if they you know calculated the
proportions of it and all that but then
again even for a game it might should be
different anyway I feel like for a game
you'd probably want them to be equal
like I'm just I'm just guessing I have
no idea like what other games like Eldon
ring and I mean even going all the way
back to
like Zelda Ocarina of Time and like how
long the night and day
I don't know I don't know I feel like
it's always been
like balanced though
but I have no idea for sure
hence one you thought cross ones would
be there the whole school year yeah
I I mean that's not even a huge spoiler
for anybody who hasn't made it before
because it's it's pretty early in the
game and it's just gone
that surprised me
oh what else what else this is actually
the the next video I've been working on
guys so
I had some other ideas too let me see
here
let me see here
oh yeah we got two more news stories to
get to as well but this is what always
happens
oh yeah let me check the poll question
let me check the poll
I want to see what how many of you guys
have said you've beaten it
oh wow 148 votes 53 say yeah wow 47 of
you hanging out still haven't beating
the game all right we'll be make sure to
be very careful with spoilers
so yeah our poll question if you haven't
voted in it yet guys I'll leave it up
for a couple more minutes have you
beaten the story in Hogwarts Legacy yet
yes or no pretty simple straightforward
have you beaten it yet I think that's
good that's really good perspective
though because in the online world like
everybody in my
conversations I feel like everybody's
beating it everybody's just blasting
through it so quickly
when in reality there's a lot of people
out there who just like to take their
time enjoy games
enjoy them slowly I should say not that
you can't enjoy them when you play fast
because you can
like a whole club actually
yeah yeah that would have been such a
cool idea to have like a whole dueling
Club where you
you can just keep going back to it and
and you get like new opponents or
opponents that improve slightly or
so yeah who knows if they'll look to
that with DLC or if they could if they
could try to do it in the main game
yeah amazing cjb that's what we were
getting ready that's one of our next
news stories here
you haven't played it yet Hylian are you
wait are you on the other other gin
other console
Destiny think it would be cool if the
companions could follow you like in
Skyrim so that they feel like companions
after you beat the relationship line oh
interesting I mean I think that'd be
cool too I feel like that's more of a
sequel
thing though I feel like that's a system
that they
I don't feel like it's built into the
game
to where they could do that easily
through an update maybe through a DLC
if it was like a really big DLC but I
almost feel like it would require a
whole a whole new game
but yeah so the other big one so the
first story we talked about was the DLC
conversation which they're saying no
current plans
I still think it's coming it's just a
matter of when
uh and then let's see which one was next
this one oh wow this one was updated
four days ago actually I haven't read
the update all right so we'll save that
one
Hogwarts Legacy tops 267 million hours
played fan interest surpasses Fantastic
Beasts
so this is amazing which any of you have
been hanging out in our live stream for
the past six months and watching our
videos for the past two years
you're probably not surprised because we
saw a lot of signs a lot of signs that
there were people excited about this
game
and also that the people working on it
were incredibly incredibly passionate
and excited for it
and that
has now transpired it has now happened
it has now happened so this was an
article from variety which it talked
about this but I think the most
interesting part about all of this
is when they talked to the president CEO
of Warner Brothers
uh one of our WB Games president David
Hadad
so David said the player engagement is
spectacular so far we have tracked over
152 million hours played 173 million
magical plants grown 150 million potions
brewed and 556 million dark Wizards
defeated
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot of
uh fighting going on in this game
for updated stats okay yeah a lot of
those stat just just crazy but then
here's the big one guys here's the big
one
Warner Brothers sees Hogwarts Legacy as
a long term
franchise
and then here you go the president
straight from the president's mouth we
are very pleased with the initial launch
and see a bright future for our other
platform launches
hold on I thought there was one more
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah our
goal is to continue to utilize our
amazing library of Warner Brothers uh
Discovery franchises as we develop our
future slate of games
and franchise is King when it comes to
today's content
and then I thought there was another
part
oh maybe it was just I thought man I
thought there was a quote from him where
it actually
I mean I don't think they would have
printed that if they didn't get that
vibe from him though
Oh I thought that was actually a quote
from him though the part about the
long-term franchise
but yeah again no surprise
no surprise
Harley out of Hogwarts dueling clubs
underground where you can battle enemies
in a safe environment for tournament
style winnings I mean sort of like the
dark arts Arenas I guess just not with
uh Evil dark Wizards
Graham fairly close to the end not
finished yet Beat the Boss didn't see
final credits hey will you you still
have a
like so you've beaten I would say the
main story there's still a little bit
more in terms of story
but and then you got a lot if you want
to do all the side quests and stuff
yes David for sure for sure I'd love to
see more HUD options a dynamic HUD to
where
when you're not in battle the Spells and
all go away I think that would be really
nice like a little a quality of life
and the map I can't decide how I feel I
feel like
oh the map too
because when I played through the story
I disabled my map I did not use the map
at all guys didn't use it at all I'm
talking about the mini map of the big
map absolutely had to use that a lot
but the uh the mini map I didn't use now
that I'm just going for 100 I've turned
the map on
and I'm using it now but man the game is
just like when you're especially when
you're looking around Hogwarts and
you're flying around the Highlands
oh the hood like I just I sometimes I
just want it out of the way and that's
that's kind of the point of a photo mode
is like the photo mode you go into photo
mode it takes away all the HUD elements
puts the game on it's it looks its best
so even if you're playing the way it
works in most games even if you're
playing on like the performance mode
which is going to give you the best
frame rate but not the best picture when
you go into the photo modes
these games will automatically like have
this trigger that will that will show
you the best Fidelity because the game
it doesn't have to move it can just
freeze it in that one state so it can
have everything look as good as it needs
to look or as good as it can look in the
game
I feel
oh man I don't know how if I had to put
a guess on Photo mode I mean I feel like
it's got to be high
I feel like it's got to be high of
eventually coming
I would say
85 chance that we get a photo mode
85 percent
if I had to put a percent on it
amazing cjb do I need to play with other
houses for exclusive quests and story
um without giving away too much there is
one fairly
there's one Quest
that is very different based on which
house you're playing
and it's really just that Quest and
that's it you still all end up basically
in the same place after the quest uh
dialogue is a little bit different based
on what your house which house you are
and you're going to get different
conversations with certain characters
because if you're in their house then
you're going to meet them sooner than
you would otherwise
so there are certain characters in the
game that you might get different
dialogue from
based on that but yeah you do if you're
going for 100 getting the trophies
achievements all that you do have to
play all the houses up to a certain
point in the game which is fairly early
in but it is it is enough into the game
where
it's not just something You're Gonna
Knock Out in an hour you're gonna have
to play a little bit on each house to
get it
Trent welcome in how's it going
camera is blurring out
which camera my camera
hold on let me zoom in on me a little
bit more maybe that will uh it has like
auto focus I don't know if that's what's
going on
oh this is one of my favorites in the
game right here
[Music]
keep it right there maybe that'll be
better
which one is this
oh it doesn't actually say
oh there's the name of each track it
looks like they haven't added like
chapters yet
maybe they'll eventually add the little
markers so we can tell
what's playing
I'm gonna turn it up just a little bit
this one's so good
wish they had more things very soon I
think it'll be a little bit though
because they gotta make sure they get
they get it out on the other platforms
like completely hubless for a while need
the map to get every
uh to get now to get everything yeah
I tried it without spells too but man
that was too hard without even seeing
the Spells
I did try it though Craig I did try it
appreciate it Trent yeah we're still
early we're still very early but
it's been it's been fun so far
I think they should
buy do I think they should buy mounts in
future I don't know what you mean by by
maybe like add more mounts
I'd love to see the Mad dragons at some
point that could be a really fun DLC
love to see an online game you can have
your own shop to sell stuff customize it
in story mode
yeah I mean a lot of people want to see
something in the Wizarding World that's
online that has a
some sort of Cooperative element to it
because for so many of us the Wizarding
World is about
it's about Community it's about a lot of
the people that you've met along the
journey and
the books are about friendship right and
that's just a huge huge huge piece of
the whole fandom so
I mean I I don't know if it would be
Avalanche
because I think they've done such a good
job telling like this like a story
and I don't think it could be this game
like I just don't think that's how they
built this game unless it just came
totally out of left field right you know
like maybe goes to tsushima style
where it's a completely separate mode
but I mean you can rest assured I mean I
think well we just read from WB right
there like I think they know
I think they hear hear the cries for
things like that and I mean there is
Harry Potter magic awaken which I know
is a very you know
it's kind of a niche thing right I think
it's like card based battling but you
can still there's a lot of cool stuff in
that in that game that you can do but
it's still not out over here for some
reason
still not out
Hogwarts Legacy director's cut with
photo mode and DLC
oh like a Game of the Year Edition or
something
well I don't even think they would have
to release like a new addition for that
I mean
for photo mode photo mode that shouldn't
be like an add-on thing for any sort of
future version I mean that should be in
this game
which God of War Ragnarok they had to do
it after launch too and I mean I get it
right it's not like
not a high priority thing before before
launch
when on their list of things to have
taken care of before the game ships
Automotive is just not gonna be at the
top of anybody's lists understandably I
mean there there's a lot of other things
that take priority over that
[Music]
grasslands bavarium Craig you think
that's the one
America welcome how's it going there's a
slot for a mystery fourth mount
that's right I was looking at that the
other day
and I thought I figured it out
because hold on if you have well it
depends right if you pre-ordered if you
didn't pre-order if you have the Onyx
hippogriff if you don't have the Onyx
hippogriff
because you got thestral
if you if you um
if you got the dark arts you get the
thestral if you pre-ordered any you get
the Onyx hippogriff and the regular
hippogriff
then you get the grab horn
Final Fantasy 14 pretty much that Harry
Potter could do that easy I feel like
another Studio we need to do yeah it
feels it feels like it would need to be
a whole
I mean because an MMO guys it's complete
it's a different style of game
different style of game there are some
similarities for sure there are
definitely some similarities but
I mean sign me up dude like where were
we talking about this was it on the uh
no it was
it was nightly nerd who said this fellow
Hogwarts Legacy creator
I can't remember there were so many live
streams before the game came out I can't
even remember where I was watching him
if it was with um
Sly the ore or if it was with podcast
now or somebody but he was on and they
were talking about like you know like
other ideas and such
and he was talking about like a
a Wizarding World MMO like Destiny Style
game
and I was just like absolutely dude sign
me up I used to play so much destiny
so much played a ton of Destiny 1 a lot
of Destiny 2 at the beginning but I
haven't played in years now which I
heard the big big apparently a really
big uh update today
really big update
magic Awakening will be fun being able
to play yeah yeah I want to try it out
Jenny I want to try it out
I know James our buddy expect to go has
played at some
[Music]
but I didn't I didn't do any of the beta
stuff because you couldn't carry over
anything it's like ah I don't want to
spend all that time playing if I can't
actually bring it over once the game
comes out
for trial quests just came up want to
finish it but I don't want to finish it
moonlace no well I mean at least you
still you still have a lot of side
quests right that's where when I get
really sad is when I saw my quest page
go to none
hmm
that made me really sad when that
happened
Auden or Auden welcome how's it going
Final Fantasy 7 remake photo mode for
the DLC a year later oh wow oh I hope we
don't have to wait a year for photo mode
I hope we don't have to wait a year
[Music]
but again I get it it's just not
there are other priorities you know
which from what I've heard you know in
talking to
game developers who worked on this game
and listening to other interviews with
game developers I mean
it's always an issue of
where do you devote your time right they
hear they hear most all the ideas guys
trust me and a lot of them they probably
even had themselves
if you don't think they originally
wanted quidditch in this game
after playing through the game I mean if
you guys seen all the references to
quidditch all the jokes made about the
lack of no Quidditch
I thought it was hilarious I mean
clearly like cell phone they're very
self-aware of okay yeah
people aren't gonna like that we don't
have quidditch so we might as well just
make fun of the fact that there's no
quidditch right
Kelpie Mount oh Kelpie Mount would be so
cool
I honestly thought
if I had to guess I think I would have
guessed that there would be a kelpie
Mount before the game launched Craig
and I don't know if it was because of
the Kelpie robe or what but I just Oh I
thought there was a chant I thought
there was a good chance there might be
one in here
have I checked Final Fantasy previews no
no I haven't
I think a lot of people would be into an
MMO but I also think a lot of people
I I think it would definitely do well
don't get me wrong but a lot of people
who love the story
I've talked to a lot of people man I
mean a lot of them probably even here in
this stream right now who
who they just they like single player
you know they like
going through a game on their own not
having to group up with anybody else
they like a good well-told story
and they don't want to do all the grindy
MMO stuff because it's a it's a very
different like that's what I meant when
I said like it's a different type of
game like the the loop has to be
different right
the gameplay Loop has to be much
different
true three I don't really care for
quidditch tater
I mean
I hesitate to say it because I I don't
want to make anybody upset but I'm kind
of right there with you like I feel like
Quidditch
to do it right
it almost has to be its own game like
you have to put an entire team on that
I feel like you have to put an entire
team on that because think about it guys
the old games they did it but the way
they did it is you were Harry you played
one position
all they had to worry about programming
was all the other stuff just happening
around you the game ends it was very
convenient the game ends when you catch
the snitch
but how would how would they make that
how far down this rabbit hole do we want
to go
because the Quidditch question
it's a it's a big one it's a big one
even going back to quidditch World Cup
because it's like when you play another
position how do they make that position
actually have
value right and be fun because the
Seeker let's be honest the way it's
written in the books The Seeker is like
it's op vert to put it in video game
terms it's op
so imagine like if it's this online
quidditch you know and everybody's
playing their own position
and you have a Seeker that's just like
terrible
and they they you lose in five seconds
or
you have two Seekers where it's taking
forever it was just like I feel like
they would almost have to rewrite the
rules Troy Troy uh who worked on
Troy Levitt was talking about this
recently in his latest interview with
Alex
he was talking about that and like how
you would have to almost tweak the rules
a bit
but yeah so in those old games it was it
was more straightforward like you're
hairy they don't have to worry about all
the stuff because hey when you catch the
snitch game is over everything happening
around you doesn't really matter
if they had if they had put it in here
and I guarantee you they when they were
first storyboarding and planning
everything out for sure they wanted to
have quidditch in there for sure it's
such an iconic part of the Wizarding
World
but I'm sure it became a matter of like
if we do this
what else is gonna get cut what else is
not gonna be in for something that
admittedly yes there's a lot of people
who really want it but then you have
just as many people like like Tater here
and like Alicia earlier today over on
Twitch who are like eh
not really that interested in it you
might play once you might play twice and
that's it for something that's a
complete aside to the game
so I don't know man like I I feel
I don't think it's going to be a DLC for
this game I don't and I hope
I don't want to upset people and I'm
just guessing I could be totally wrong
like me
maybe their work maybe it's done
maybe they already did it it was kept in
secret and it's ready to go right
but I would be really surprised I'd be
really surprised
Ed says own game for sure
if they add DLC
they might start with VR2
oh VR I was like wait VR2 PlayStation VR
just cast the Spells with your hand
CMU store wouldn't you get tired they
would have to make it to where that's
not the only option though
it'd be cool
for like an hour I feel like
they'll be okay I want to sit down my
hand's getting tired
I mean you guys know how many times we
were like basic casting in this game
[Music]
but I I know there were some things
where people were already working on
trying to get not not anything official
but people were already trying to make
it work with VR
Jenny in the same boat not too bothered
there isn't quidditch would love to play
if it had its own properly done game
yeah I would try it out especially if it
had like online and stuff
14 year olds play all my multiplayer
games
love to see Ivor morning
I agree Craig
and as much as I would love to see a
whole game based on it I think it'd be
really hard to do
because once you take it out of Hogwarts
man then it's it's a much tougher cell
to people who are only kind of casually
following the world right like this game
the reason it is succeeding the way it
is
there's a lot of Die Hard Harry Potter
fans but there's a lot of
sort of you know casual Harry Potter
fans too I mean it's part of the
mainstream Harry Potter's part of the
mainstream right everybody's at least
familiar with Harry Potter most people
have seen at least one movie
but dude like it is it is getting
advertised like crazy man and whoever
the commercial they're doing
I don't know if you guys have seen the
ad
it's so freaking good man that has the
cuts of the movie
and cuts of the game and it's like
remember watching watching Harry's
Journey Through The Wizarding World now
live your own I'm just like oh my gosh
they're crushing it
what great marketing
but yeah my wife and I were watching
watching HBO and ESPN it's on there so
it's like oh they're hitting all the
range of
age groups and different channels
foreign
of it or maybe have have to help the
team find something related more of a
puzzle exploration gotcha
Italian Quidditch game with Hogwarts
Legacy could be done if could be good if
done properly okay yeah that'd be
interesting if it was like a standalone
like it's part of this world
um
I'm still trying to form my my DLC plan
too which is like
doesn't matter what I say guys but like
what I would most like to see
because the thing I'm worried about if
they just go straight to a sequel
the thing I'm worried about is when we
roll around for year six
do we you can't start as a new student I
I don't feel like you can
I feel like you gotta carry through this
character now if you're if you didn't
play the first game then obviously they
gotta have a way to kind of funnel them
into the experience
but then it would just be so weird like
I don't feel like this is a game where
you can do the our character has Amnesia
and they forgot all their spells and
then you have to learn them all again
and
and then what do you do about the
secrets in Hogwarts what do you do about
the secrets in Hogwarts if you just make
a sequel like you you gotta have secrets
in Hogwarts right but you already did it
you already have you have all the field
guy Pages like what
I guess that's their job right I mean
that's that's a game developer shop but
for me
I've said this a couple times now on
streams this is just where I kind of
keep Landing
I don't know if they would do this
because I don't know if it would I mean
it all like at the end of the day it
comes back to like what would make the
most money right like a sequel a sequel
almost has to happen
but if I like if I were writing it out
in my perfect world here's what I would
do I would do year six Hogwarts Legacy
DLC
like Witcher blood and wine or something
like a big big big expansion
give them a year and a half whatever you
know I don't know development times
these days like if that's enough time
for it but just build on everything you
already have
build on everything all the assets
everything you already have you know
make this get the glitches get the bugs
fixed
all that year six
new story new Quest you're taking your
character you're jumping right back into
the world man you don't even have to
like you don't have to worry about
losing your spells you go into year six
oh I think they could do it so well
because you have so much of the
foundation already there
you're six you're seven DLCs
and I know everybody else is gonna say
and I mean I said too for the longest
time I was like oh it's set up perfectly
for a Trilogy you're five you're six
you're seven game one game two game
three
but now like seeing how it all plays out
I think it'd be better like that dude
a couple of mini DLCs in between like to
lead up to them but then the big one is
year six DLC Hogwarts Legacy year six
Hogwarts Legacy year seven then
then you get the big sequel
and from there there's a lot of things
they could do right they could
they could start anew they could tell a
new character story
a new person arriving in Hogwarts or
my personal favorite idea
we keep our same character this
character that we've created here in
Hogwarts Legacy we have them year six in
DLC we have them in year seven in DLC
and then we carry them into the sequel
and I see two big paths they could go
two big pass path one
you're an or you're working for the
ministry
tons of story stuff they could do with
that right
or option two
you're a professor at Hogwarts
because I still feel like no matter what
they do Hogwarts
almost has to be at the central of it it
almost has to be at the central
yes I would love ilvermorny man I would
love to see a game fully based on over
morning but trust me guys
ilvermorny Legacy would not sell
like Hogwarts Legacy Hogwarts Legacy
ilver Morning Edition would not sell
like Hogwarts like C2 just wouldn't it
just wouldn't man because the vast
majority that's over morning is not a
mainstream thing Hogwarts is mainstream
so maybe you could go to those other
places I think that's a bit the first
sequel I feel like that's the biggest
thing they could do
which I don't want to spoil things too
much for people who haven't
uh play through all the story yet but
I'm just saying hufflepuffs
the special story stuff you got not fair
not fair hufflepuffs
[Music]
not fair
is multiplayer coming Aaron ass like PVP
so they've said no
and I don't think so
that was one thing that leading up to
the game I actually thought for a while
had a good chance to happen
but then once the community manager
Channel wood took over I mean he pretty
early on
and if you read through the FAQ they
printed pretty definitively stated like
this is a single player open world
action RPG
so if it did I feel like that'd be a
little bit of a curveball be a bit of a
surprise
pretty new on the channel which house
are you I am gryffindoll
and sorry I know I got a little behind
on Chad I was just dude when you guys
get me going on these ideas I can just
roll with it
I could just roll with it
hunt hunting your retro glad I got to a
stream before it ended hey good to have
you here welcome in Lauren D more
magical Beast I think that is a great
absolutely I feel like that's almost a
lock
for like a deal a future DLC that may be
a couple more spells more stories maybe
some more mini games like I feel like
those are
those are as close to a lock as you can
get
foreign
[Music]
because they're only what I think 13
total beasts
well I guess that's just counting
there's a lot more if you count the ones
you sort of meet up with out in the wild
right
but yeah I don't know hold on now that I
think about that I was so sure at first
like more beasts oh yeah but now
I still agree with you it'd be cool but
I don't know maybe it's more like 50 50
than as close as at first I was feeling
pretty confident but more I thought
about it
different timeline that's another option
cjb yeah they could go different
timeline
that's the big thing a lot of people
want to talk about try wizard
they could do try wizard but they would
just have to be like to make it fit
within the lore because
it was such a big deal and gobbled a
fire because that was the first time
they had tried it in a long time
so I think Dumbledore
yeah because Dumbledore's a lot I mean
we know he's alive in this time period
even though he hasn't started Hogwarts
yet
so yeah I because try wizard I mean
everybody says try wizard because it's
it's so
it's just a perfect setup for a video
game it really is but
I guess the only way they could do that
stay true to lures set it in a different
time period
Dustin I don't think that would sell man
I don't think that would sell franchise
could just be Legacy and folks on one
School per game
I don't think it would sell
not it does not have the mainstream
power
that Hogwarts Legacy has now over time
I'm talking a long period of time maybe
they could build into that
maybe but that that would take a lot of
time
a lot of time to reach that point
your six and seven DLC yeah that's what
I'm saying
have to play The Witcher now oh yeah I
love The Witcher
more spells I feel like that's a good
shot
I feel like that's a good shot to happen
Nico you think so too yeah that's what
I'm saying dude that's what I'm saying
Nico said Hogwarts likely doesn't need a
sequel it needs to do year sixes DLC yep
you're six and seven DLC
and I'm talking I mean they need to be
like beefy beefy DLCs dude like
so like all of the tutorial stuff that
we had in this game which there was a
lot of it because we're fifth year
starting for the first like there was a
lot of that stuff think of all that
getting removed
and then just everything in the DLC is
just like a big new story with all these
new quests
the professors
they're back you've got that to carry
over
and then they're like oh we could just
call this Hogwarts like
but I guess the reason the reason I keep
coming back to it is I think it could
just work as a DLC is because
I don't I don't want them to have to
reset
a lot of the stuff at Hogwarts I don't
want us to have to start the game and
not know any of the Spells which to be
fair
I mean you could do that in a sequel too
just have the character start with
everything they already had but then
you're gonna have that weird tutorial
where they have to accommodate people
who may be playing that game without
playing the other game
which there would be a small a small
group I feel like but you have to you
have to do that like it just has to be
part of the game
[Music]
um oh man I love talking about this
stuff
I hope so Nicholas yeah I hope so
it's so nice if they continue the
character long term
making Hogwarts feel new feel new again
will be interesting to see David that
yeah that's exactly what I'm saying
Field Guide Pages wouldn't be a thing
right you can't you couldn't do the
field guy Pages again
it'd have to be something else
which
their their game developers they're
clearly very creative have a great team
maybe they could come up with enough
things
to make Hogwarts feel like totally fresh
and new and have all this fun stuff to
discover but like how
dude how much of this game guys the part
of the greatness of this game is that
Discovery right within Hogwarts
and you just you can't you couldn't you
can't change Hogwarts like if you in in
a sequel
you couldn't be like oh well we're gonna
add this room over here and then this
room's gone and then we're gonna add a
new wing and
yeah we just couldn't do that
magic zoologist professional quidditch
player yeah there's some options if they
went with like careers and stuff
yeah that's what I'm saying Dustin they
already have a bunch of former Ministry
workers Ministry Magic
100 whether it's DLC whether it's a
sequel we gotta go to the ministry man
see the reason I love the aura idea for
a like a long-term future sequel is
because then you can kind of keep
Hogwarts at the center especially if
we're maybe we're working at the
SchoolTube or something like you know
you're going back and forth but then
that opens up the whole world that opens
up the whole world and once you have a
character that can once we're old enough
to operate
you can take us anywhere man you take us
literally that open world game could be
anywhere you want it to be
curse breaker like pyramids you know
Azkaban Ministry God I saw godrics
Hollow in the chat right there's so many
and the pensives right we saw a lot of
that in this game again not spoiling too
much for those who are still playing but
pencils like if you want to relive any
event in Wizarding World History they
can make it happen through the pensive
all right so I'm gonna go ahead and end
the poll that was actually a lot closer
than I thought though the final results
of the poll 56 percent have beaten the
game 44 have not beaten the game yet
[Music]
they got the best Quest I know
freaking hufflepuffs
[Music]
put the Hogwarts Legacy Saga in the
title so people know for sure for sure
but
if Hogwarts Legacy is in the title and
you don't spend much time at Hogwarts
people gonna be like what
what come on man
come on agrosexy2 should be returning as
a teacher 20 years later
that could work that could work
Trav thank you for the sub welcome in
you could do it as where when we
graduate we choose a job have all of
England open to us
I love the idea Templar but then like if
you if you could choose a job
well that's like how many different
choices right and then you got to make
completely different games based on
the choice you made right I feel like
that would be more in the MMO route if
if we ever get an MMO in The Wizarding
World
SP for sure dude for sure
it is truly
huge possibilities for the things they
could do
uh I'm fine cjb that they didn't have a
Potter in Legacy they wanted to tell
their own story I mean I think that's
why they stayed away
from the major players like Dumbledore
but I thought they did a good job I
thought it was a nice balance of like
familiarity of
hey you're gonna recognize some of these
names even some of these characters
right when we're talking about ghosts
and stuff
but it was it was a separate story it
was a completely new story to us in the
Wizarding World even all the stuff that
we learned through pensives like I
thought that stuff was pretty cool
I thought that stuff was really cool I
know uh
our buddy expect to go was a little
surprised
maybe a wee bit disappointed
that it's it wasn't tied to a certain
other ancient wizard
hey dreaming
perfect segue perfect segue
Hogwarts Legacy TV show
let's talk about this
let's talk about this one giant freaking
robot exclusive Hogwarts Legacy show
in the works and I'll be honest with you
guys I've been preaching for a long time
hey this is going to be big this is
going to be big this is going to be big
uh not even I saw this coming and let's
be clear on this one of all of
everything we talked about I mean I
think this is firmly in the rumor
category
I would say firmly in the rumor category
however apparently these guys have been
reliable before our sources have reached
out to let us know HBO Max is developing
a series based on the game
Hogwarts Legacy
and then they have a lot of stuff in
here about controversy which I'm like
okay are you reporting on the news or
are you just like
injecting a bunch of other stuff anyway
I digress uh let's get to the actual
oh my gosh they really did bury it
didn't they let's get to the actual news
bit
are you kidding me hold on I'm gonna
have to do a
control F here
what point do they finally
yeah then it got kind of weird at the
end because they say
dude where the heck do they actually
okay right here are trusted and proven
okay so it was it was up there but they
had to get this they had to get this
line in there first didn't they our
trust and proven sources tell us a
Hogwarts Legacy series is in development
at HBO Max
that is
big
and let's see if they had anything else
because I I'll be honest with you guys I
really hadn't even looked into this one
too in depth yet
part of what is rendered Hogwarts looks
so popular unlike Harry Potter players
of the game have the opportunity to be a
part of the houses other than
Potter's Gryffindor allowing fans of the
franchise seething from different points
of view
players are treated to an open world
allowing them to explore Hogwarts the
nearby hogsmeade and more
uh
developing Hogwarts Legacy for the
screen might be the Studio's way of
seeing whether or not they can keep the
franchise relevant on another platform
they can
if they want to
the series okay here we go finally
getting to the meat of it the series is
still in the early phases of development
so few details are available
presumably like the game the Hogwarts
Legacy series will be set before either
the original Harry Potter novels and
even before the Fantastic Beasts
spin-offs the game takes place in the
19th century though there are some
semi-familiar names such as Professor
Matilda Weasley an ancestor of the
novel's heroic Weasley family
and then controversy controversy
controversy blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah
uh while it's far too early okay this
was part was like okay this is weird
it's far too early to make any
statements about the cast we wouldn't
necessarily dismiss the notion of Harry
Potter alums showing up in the Hogwarts
Legacy series you just literally said it
was set way before the time of Harry
Potter so
yeah so clearly uh not a lot of details
on this which did they did they say what
the update was four days ago
so they must have just made some change
but we don't know what
the update was because you see right
here it says updated four days ago
oh man all right what is my guess on
this what is my spin
I think
in the works is a very broad term is it
not
it's a very broad term
I would say
given the success of this game WB is
probably talking about a lot of
different things for Hogwarts Legacy so
TV show is probably on the table I I
think we could say for sure they're
discussing it
in the works though like does that mean
it's 100 happening I don't I don't
follow the TV industry as closely as I
do the gaming industry but I know this
from following just video game over the
years that they people have said oh this
is getting turned into a movie or this
is getting turned into a TV show and
then they never happen
is a very long list it's a very long
list
that's why the last of us like I just
didn't even think it was happening for
the longest time
Uncharted dude they talked Uncharted
they tried so many times before that
movie finally got made there were so
many rumors you're a wizard so this is
not something that I think you would
look for tomorrow
next year probably not even the next two
years right maybe we get information on
it in the next two years if it's
officially happening but yeah I mean WB
is for sure they're probably talking
about hey can we do movies can we do TV
shows can we do games
what else what else can we do around
Hogwarts Legacy
do we go there's already been talk about
you know they're talking about remaking
the movies they're talking about
um doing TV shows that in different eras
so
I I want to see more I guess I want to
see more but the fact that like this is
a rumor and again giant freaking robot
it seems that they have reported things
like this in the past and been correct
so I think it's exciting
I think it's really exciting and it
would be super interesting to see
how they do that as a TV show because
like they even I mean even they even
touch on there in the article one of the
biggest things about Hogwarts Legacy is
the fact that it's our story
so if you move it to a TV show well then
you're gonna have to tell somebody
else's story which
the professors you guys man I thought
they were great
Ronin garlic Weasley black
uh fig
um who else who am I forgetting whom I
forgetting the caretaker oh my gosh
Gladwin Moon
there are like those they've got some
good professors man that you could make
I could I could already see them coming
to life on on the screen
and telling some really good stories
around those characters
but it's like do you said it before our
character arrives at Hogwarts
because it like I don't see how they
could tie in our story you know our
character I think it has to be set like
a little bit before
which would probably be the safest
because then you don't have to worry
about getting to Dumbledore maybe maybe
this this TV show could be like before
we get to Hogwarts right like the lead
up to that
all right I'm way behind on chat let me
let me catch up
uh it'd be funny if we are Albus dumbled
or not oh my gosh could you imagine
Slytherin
DLC getting uh letting leading into the
sequel
I'm hoping nightly that's kind of what
I'm hoping
[Music]
Hogwarts is mainstream school people
don't really know a lot about right
right wag doing over morning yeah
that's what I'm saying Destiny you're 67
DLC
I was a developer of Hogwarts Legacy get
big DLCs for your six seven in two years
awkward sexy third year would be a
sequel or you mean like the third game
would be a sequel or no wait the third
year
third year I don't know what you meant
by Third Year there but I think you were
saying the same thing that I was saying
yeah what will happen around Sebastian
see that's why I think it might be
easier
oh you guys are talking about for DLC or
sequel
okay yeah
not sport we have 44 of people watching
who haven't finished the story so I
don't want to say too much but yeah
there's some big decisions to be made
regarding Sebastian in your story as you
progress
so yeah they would have to work that out
plus I mean plus the character the
decision that our character makes at the
end too
you can have a tutorial that you skip
through if you import your character oh
yeah yeah yeah you could do something
like that
diagonally oh my gosh yes we needed we
need Diagon Alley
we need Diagon Alley they need a mass
effect story style see this is how far
behind I am in chat you guys aren't even
on to the TV show stuff yet
oh my gosh me store I never thought
about that level 40 for this level 73 or
six level 100 for year seven that
actually works out quite nicely
[Music]
you want to go to work be a full-blown
adult wizard
new to your job tutorial see yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
I think Professor would be cool too
Tater I do
possibility as a DLC they could do
honestly so exciting I agree dreaming I
agree you dude you gotta know they're
just giddy right now as excited as they
were by the way go ninja go hold on hold
on hold on five minutes ago Go Ninja Go
renewing their tier one that's the four
months for go ninja go thank you very
much for continuing that sub or that
membership
thank you very much my friend
appreciate it
40 hours in just made it to fall
nice
rumor of requirement yeah that's a big
one where they could add a lot of stuff
like the idea of having the sequel focus
on your characters life as an adult
wizard first game focuses a lot on
exploration a sequel would need to
narrow in on another aspect yeah yeah
yeah
Jenny a show based on the game this
makes me nervous yeah I mean if it's HBO
and if
if they get the folks like Alan and
Boston involved in terms of helping them
I was talking to somebody on Twitter
about this like I don't know that
Avalanche has like I don't know Alan's
background enough to know if he would be
interested in directing a TV show like
like Neil druckman who is doing the last
of us who played a major part in the
game The Last of Us right like I don't
know if Avalanche has anybody like that
maybe they do
but whatever the case they would
definitely need somebody to make sure
that like the attention to detail the
world the lore like that they have that
is some of the main reasons this game
has succeeded oh yeah they would make
need to make sure they did a lot of uh
Consulting and
set up with them all I mean all these
all these people that Avalanche who who
created these characters that fit and
feel such a natural part of the
Wizarding World I watched a review oh my
gosh I wish I could remember
who it was I either read the review or
watched a video on it I've watched so
much Hogwarts Legacy stuff over the past
few weeks guys I don't even know but
somebody was like I actually like these
professors better than
the professors in the original book
which I'm like okay I don't know if I'll
go that far but I agree like they fit
they fit in perfectly you know
Miriam and figs passed and how it leads
into the game true true
yeah that LC true it's kind of
surprising there hasn't been a show
already
finished the game in a couple days Levi
oh you went through quick
imagine Disney got Wizarding World
rights and read the books as a show oh
my goodness
what kind of series and where exactly
right like when
where does it fall in the timeline
before our arrival I feel like it would
have to be
that's where I met cjb like HBO dude
they they I'm not gonna say they don't
miss but they pretty darn close to not
missing like they do such a good job
anchor the main character story no
longer owned yeah see I think they would
have to pick a different
if it's HBO dude they might not even
focus on a student
they might not even focus on a student
they might focus on a professor
that might be the way to go have the
professors be the main characters
and that way Hogwarts Legacy as a game
can still be our story
means in the concept phase right yeah I
feel like it's just like they're talking
about the possibilities kind of where I
feel
if Done Right a show could work maybe
tell it from the perspective of
non-player characters in the game
teacher students Etc
I'd even think about like um
like the different shopkeepers and stuff
hogsmeade
look at the Game of Thrones Ben right
like even something as big as Game of
Thrones good point Owen that had
so much backing behind it right
only one is only one of those right
apparently there's still a Jon Snow show
coming too but
yeah
so it's still very very early
ready to sign up for the Hogwarts Legacy
movie
ominous says the main character
ominous is a great character that's all
I'm gonna say
Ronan yeah Ronan Ronan will be really
fun black made me laugh yeah if they got
Simon Pegg for the show
David's the sloth already said there
would be more Harry Potter movies yeah I
mean he even talked about
it was almost like they don't think they
don't consider Fantastic Beasts or Harry
Potter and then there's that big rumor
about cursed child
it's almost say that
big rumor about the cursed Child movie
a Janet renewing their membership thank
you so much Janet for the support
appreciate you
heck it right right heck it sharp they
did such a good job with the backstories
for these characters
that they could really do a lot of fun
with the story
no problem go ninja nice to catch a
stream again
working late oh you've been working late
on Tuesdays
Dumbledore prequel dreaming I think
I don't think they're gonna touch
Dumbledore
and I think that's part of the re part
of the reason that
like I never understood why Fantastic
Beasts suddenly turned into Dumbledore's
story
I don't know if that was Joe's original
plan I mean I guess it was because she
had such a big part in it
but it was like why wouldn't you just
like I feel like
it's almost like that should have been
two separate stories like I know Newt
played a major role in it but it's like
we could have just had this fun little
Newt and his adventures like that that's
what I thought when Fantastic Beasts
first came out that's what I thought it
was gonna be
and then it just ended up being oh
here's Dumbledore and here's all this
stuff leading up to Grindelwald that we
heard about and
you know some people liked it some
people didn't
regardless of where you fall on that it
clearly didn't meet their expectations
in terms of the money they were hoping
it would make but
yeah so I feel like Hogwarts Legacy may
be showing them that you know what let's
just
Let's either go to that side of it or
go to the other side and it's just like
hey Harry Potter's back
this is a show about him as an adult you
know
but that would require a lot a lot a lot
to happen
for us to ever get to that point
Professor sharp is your favorite for
some reason I mean sure I feel like they
they all are just so unique
so I didn't I feel like sharp I probably
interacted with
the least
show could touch on the four Founders
creating Hogwarts quickly leads up to
when the character our character starts
at Hogwarts
um
Terrell odd love of an anime anytime
I've ever posted that idea though it
gets shot down
I feel like
I feel like there's a Wizarding World
story that could be told very well in
anime
but
I don't know I don't know if we would
ever get it
Dr sherbet would like a whole new story
nothing that's from the main stories is
that that's what works so well in the
game yeah yeah for sure
you haven't even played it yet Lauren
listening to us talk about it way
appreciate everybody uh keeping things
relatively spoiler free tonight
since we still have so many who haven't
played
focus on ran rock as a main character
dude okay I'm not spoiling but
there is something you can learn about
ranrock in this game which
my gosh guys if you were watching the
stream I don't even remember if we were
on Twitch or on YouTube but where did we
find it
it's like a letter you find
that tells you about ran Rock's past and
gives you way more insight into him
way more than you than you pick up on
through anything else in the game but
it's a completely different look on his
character and I was like when I read it
I thought I wish that had been
I wish that had been featured more
prominently
but then but then but then I also love
the idea that it's just like the small
thing that you find and when you find it
you feel like it was such a
that added so much to my
to the story in my head knowing that bit
of information
still want to Rave a clock opinion right
feathers dude after playing the game
feathers I feel like
I feel like it was pretty clearly part
of the plan
again I'm trying not to spoil the People
Too Much you haven't played but
I mean there are certain quests
involving Ravenclaw where you could feel
like okay this is the character that was
meant to be the companion but maybe just
things got cut and didn't didn't make it
in yeah yeah yeah
you episodes just dedicated to Sebastian
[Music]
well
we'll need to finish the game first
you'll need to finish the game first
maybe you already have wubby but
yeah I don't want to talk too much about
Sebastian because of the big big story
stuff that happens with him
what about the ministry or as
unspeakables during this time period
yeah
not the face palm it curse job
[Music]
cases they went on would probably make
some interesting episodes for sure
[Music]
Tom Riddle TV show young James Potter
and his friends Hogwarts founder a lot I
feel like the founders that's a big one
a lot of people ask for
lots of people ask about the founders
and I would I think that would be really
cool but man would it be tough to do
man I mean it would be tough tough tough
tough
not saying I wouldn't want to see
somebody try though
because you're talking like ancient
ancient times when you get into the
founders
and you would have to make sure like
there's probably so much lore you would
have to pour through to make sure that
you're you're staying true to that lore
but I would love it dude if we got to
see a different side
of a lot of the founders
because we already know we know a lot
about them
one of oh I already read that one no
cursed child but Sebastian episodes for
HBO yes
listening to the stream while chugging
along 100 nice hey hopefully we're
helping you pass the time your shot is
not canon feathers says reason the first
Fantastic Beasts movie was amazing the
rest went downhill right yes they
already had
yeah I thought the first movie was a was
fun
I mean I enjoyed parts of all of them
but it just it very quickly turned into
something that was like oh is this
really what it was intended to be
[Music]
um sort of x x Steven sort of I I have a
second character only because I needed
to get to the olive Anders part just to
do some footage record some footage for
a YouTube video but that was it I'm I'm
still on my main my main character going
100 percent
thinking more about it a show could be
about the Sears
could be could be
studio uh Ghibli art style that'd be
amazing
he was in a side quest talking to
someone to learn about ran Rock yes
feathers I I couldn't believe it was in
a side quest was so it was a person
talking it wasn't a letter okay
I knew it was something like that
Hogwarts 62 at the ministry can you
imagine how many secrets
see that's what I'm saying that's what
I'm saying but you still have to have
Hogwarts
as a Connecting Point
I feel like maybe they again we were
talking earlier about long term maybe
you get to the point where it doesn't
have to have Hogwarts as the centerpiece
but I feel like you're a long way from
that I feel like you're a long way from
that I mean I feel like that's like I'll
just be totally honest with you guys I
feel like that would be a 10-year
process
of getting for a game to be as
successful as this one I feel like it
would be a 10-year process of them
creating this Hogwarts Legacy world
have a second the DLC like we talked
about have a second game four or five
years later where Hogwarts is still the
centerpiece but you start
you start to do more stuff at the
ministry then you have that third game
where
maybe you only go to Hogwarts A couple
of times and maybe by then maybe by then
you've built up enough
momentum to where you can now say okay
look guys our next game but yeah I just
think it would be I think it would be a
long road
to get there
yeah Mac I finished the game I finished
the uh the story now I'm just going
through and 100 percenting
Merlin story a I know a couple people
would be happy with that
that could be cool
three Hillary Brothers how's it going
welcome in
Joseph hunting down the treasure vaults
nice
[Music]
Brittany originally I thought the game
was going to tie with Merlin
they yeah they do have the Merlin trials
maybe just visiting minister of magic
[Music]
yeah Elwyn yeah it was it was
interesting too because it was
it just like that's not what I thought
the story was going to be about
[Music]
major event at Hogwarts oh my gosh dude
I just thought of the idea for maybe a
possible sequel at some point you're
working for the ministry
and
some special role and then something
starts happening at Hogwarts where they
actually have to like call the ministry
in to investigate
that would be cool dude
Hogwarts Legacy murder mystery like
there's a student going crazy
yes this student with ancient Magic
some dude named Sebastian taught him AK
and they're just like they're taking out
everybody now but we can't find who it
is we don't know who it is
no no no but for real though if they had
there could be a cool story there where
you have to like come investigate
something at Hogwarts or even if you're
a professor I feel like the professor
angle could work too
we're just uh we're just spitballing
ideas David for or Elliot for possible
DLCs
Aaron is multiplayer coming I don't
think so I don't think so to Hogwarts
Legacy
too many Merlin trials I'll let you know
in a week Nico if I agree with that
what was I at today 69 70 I think
somewhere in there
I'll let you know I'll let you know how
I feel about that a lot of people have
said that though
hey Levi thank you for stopping by have
a good one
DLC you could go with Nanny and her
mother to her old school yeah like like
little trips like that
that'd be a great way to introduce other
areas
Azkaban cough cough wink wink
[Music]
wreaking hufflepuffs
um
Ministry workers that you have to go
back to Hogwarts to find out whatever
the plot yeah yeah yeah Dustin right
true Jake I mean yeah I'm not saying
it's not possible I'm just saying if you
read everything Avalanche has said about
it
they've pretty clearly been like no
and not like in a secretive wink wink
kind of way but like oh my gosh we don't
want you guys to get the wrong idea
and I credit Chandler for that I mean if
they did end up coming out with
something multiplayer it'd be the
greatest like Twist of all time dude
because we speculated about this a lot I
mean on this very Channel you can find
videos of me saying guys I think they're
gonna do something after the launch of
the game Ghost of tsushima style and
then pretty early after Chandler wood
took over as Community manager I mean
they there were some very clear
statements on the FAQ Hogwarts Legacy is
a single player game and then Chandler
in another
he was an interview or a blog post or
something he was like
basically let me be clear it's a single
player game and so I think that was
Chandler reading the community and being
like okay we don't want them to get the
wrong idea let's make sure they clearly
know that it's not multiplayer
[Music]
but as I've also said many times I think
Avalanche and WB both have heard all of
these people saying
they've seen the community building up
around this game obviously they
they had invited people like uh James
for the Showcase spin snow Lynette I had
a chance to go out play the game early
they invited all of us out there to play
the game early they clearly have a read
on the community so they're seeing this
support right and how
a lot of us are saying hey we'd love to
have stuff to do
or we could you know go through a lot of
this together right play with our
community
but I just don't know if it's Avalanche
I think it might be WB
having another Studio do it in the
future with a different type of game
and then like we've already mentioned a
couple times there is Magic awakened as
well
there's also magic awakened
[Music]
yeah I heard about that jaybird
I heard about that I'm being careful how
much I talk about it because
I haven't seen anything directly from
them yet but
um I don't get the idea that they're too
happy with
those right now
which I'm trying to figure out why
because I've seen
well I think I know why I just don't
want to say it
I don't want to say it but we shall see
we shall see because yeah there's a lot
of good things that can come from
those types of communities so I'm kind
of surprised
kind of surprised but yeah we'll see
we'll see if anything changes on that
front in the future because some of the
stuff that I've seen that people are
already doing with this game on PC is
like
so cool man so cool I mean look at
Skyrim right like they really helped
extend the life of that game
you got your first ban in chat I do not
remember that
I do not remember
hidden fourth Beast is a dragon to ride
I know everybody keeps talking about
this hidden fourth Beast
I don't know if it's just an error have
they commented on that at all like I
wonder if it's just a visual
error like with the menu like if it was
unintended or maybe they had originally
planned on having more beasts and they
they need to patch it out or whatever
[Music]
's twitch and now YouTube live what do
we do to deserve this
hey dude we're on that on that streaming
grind I gotta make sure we we stay true
to our YouTube audience as well we built
up a lot of uh
a lot we I mean we built our community
right here on YouTube with these Tuesday
night streams so I don't want to neglect
those we're going to keep trying to do
those as well as twitch streams yeah man
it's been a long day I don't know if
I'll be able to keep doing two a day we
might have to move the uh
the twitch streams to a different day
but I would love it if the fourth piece
was a dragon would love it
a PVP Arena would be pretty cool
it would
100 likes hey let's go
thank you guys for all the likes and all
the support
so I think we got through all the news
stories
I think we did so with 100 likes it's
time for a little
a little Harry Potter quote trivia
dude it's been a while since we've done
this too
so for those of you who are new here I'd
be surprised if there's anybody new
tonight
I don't know who who knows maybe
maybe there's somebody new here but
whenever we hit 100 likes on stream we
like to do something fun to interact
with the chat and so we do a
random bit of Harry Potter quote trivia
so these are the US versions of the
books
I'm just gonna pull to a random page
and try to pick a line from a character
and then you tell me the character and
the book
or bonus points
dude if this was on Twitch we could
actually do uh we could like reward
Channel points for people
all right so last time I'm trying to
remember it's been so long can't
remember if we went with a really
difficult one
oh here's one here's one here's one
all right
you guys ready
will the twitch streams always be in the
morning Eastern Time
probably start I don't know we might do
some night Friday we did a night stream
but then like today we started at 10 A.M
and we went all the way to
after five eastern
but yeah I mean I'm kind of open I'm
kind of open so I don't know did you
have something in mind Dustin like is
there a time that works better for you
we had a pretty good crowd today we had
a really good turnout over on Twitch so
yeah
first time hey there we go Izzy do you
have some first timers in here
[Music]
also Moon spark new here first time on
YouTube live oh you found me from twitch
that is so funny to hear
that's so cool to hear because it's it's
usually the other way around right
because we
we covered this game for so long on
YouTube that a lot of our people who
watch on Twitch or from here
but yeah that's cool I'm glad you guys
uh glad some people found it from there
all right here we go here's the quote
it's a two-parter so there's a part in
here where it tells the characters who
said it so I'm just gonna leave that
part out
but that's just silly said the character
you can't go to work in this state I
think you ought to go to Saint mungo's
and get them to sort you out
there it is all right so character in
book here it is one more time but that's
just silly you can't go to work in this
state I think you ought to go to Saint
mungo's and get them to sort you out
[Music]
all right so guess character and guest
book
get off at 4 30 Easter Monday through
Thursday anytime oh gotcha
yeah so we'll probably keep doing some
uh night streams too
yeah like last Friday we started at gosh
what eight and went to about 3 A.M
guess what your name is on Twitter how
would I how would I even begin to Guess
that Jake
how would I even begin
[Music]
all right so we got Molly Weasley Molly
to Arthur Order of the Phoenix wubby
says Order of the Phoenix Molly Molly
book six Molly fifth book Molly Order of
the Phoenix
where's Brittany is Brittany not here
tonight
Ron Weasley book five says Mr cold
guess what nobody's gotten it yet
nobody's gotten it yet dude
Regional tree 209 okay yeah I would have
definitely never guessed that Jake
I would have never guessed that
jaybird
boom
oh sorry Ginny sorry
so sorry Jaybird just got it
it is Hermione Granger
that was kind of tricky right Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows let's see
what chapter this is It's on page 239
but what chapter are we in
takes forever to scroll on
Kindle app on my phone
wow we were pretty much at the very end
of that chapter
chapter
goodness this is the long chapter
hey Cloud Roth with the one month
thank you so much Cloud Roth for the
membership appreciate it chapter 12
magic is might
all right and then it was on page 229
so here it was one more time
oh no wait was it 239
I've lost it
no
did I say 239
yeah 239 my bad my bad my bad
Hermione oh yeah yeah it's when she
gives the wizard The
oh the puking pastel pastel I don't even
know how you pronounce that word
oh dear she said as he splattered the
alley with sick
perhaps you'd better take the day off no
no he choked and wretched trying to
continue on his way despite being unable
to walk straight I must today must go
but that's just silly said Hermione
alarmed you can't go to work in this
state I think you ought to go to Saint
mungo's and get them to sort you out the
wizard had collapsed heaving onto all
four still trying to crawl toward the
Main Street you simply can't go to work
like this cried Hermione
at last he seemed to accept the truth of
her words
GG's too who was it that got that
Jaybird nicely done jaybird
nicely done
which Hogwarts house uh I would yeah
Gryffindor Gryffindor James
definitely wouldn't have guessed
Hermione
alternating schedule with twitch and
YouTube yeah so I think we'll probably
try and keep
the YouTube lives
I mean all right just speaking totally
honest with you guys today was hard
I shouldn't have went seven hours on
Twitch that was my fault
that was my fault
the plan was to only do like three four
hours and then get a nice little break
in before we came back live for the
night stream
but part of me wants to keep the YouTube
lives on Tuesdays just because that's
like
you know it's like
when you get a TV show that you
have the time it's like you just it's
it's like a staple right everybody knows
Tuesday night streams that's what we've
kind of built things on so I want to try
to keep the YouTube lives on Tuesday
night as I just accidentally hit the
ancient magic wand
it's still not it still remained this
whole time on its correct spot
so yeah but the twitch is gonna move
around a lot for a while until we kind
of settle into this new routine like
tomorrow my mom wasn't able to come this
week
don't even we've had like so much
sickness in our family lately so my wife
works tomorrow and then I'll probably
only be streaming on Twitch for maybe
maybe about two hours so we're gonna be
on at 9 30 a.m I'm gonna shoot for 9 30.
and that's after I dropped my youngest
off at preschool and then I'll be back
and then I have to go get him a couple
hours later
but yeah once when the kids are home
when no and my mom's not here or my
wife's not here then I just I'm not even
like that's too too hard to try and
stream then so yeah it will kind of play
it by ear but I will try to post it
Elwyn was cracking me up in the mod we
have a mod channel on Discord
and I like when I posted I was like
tentative schedule for the week guys
and I was like Hey whenever it's
whenever kids are involved it's always
tentative just you guys with kids you
already know
you already know
do you think in Hogwarts Legacy as an or
you might investigate Dumbledore father
attacking them
like in a sequel
oh my gosh it's possible
it is possible
you love the book so much listen to them
at least two times a year hey that's
awesome
which house was my second uh I think
Ravenclaw is always my second
kids come first right yep yep
basically the same not quite
you can't just like
leave them at home you know
you can't just leave the by themselves
that doesn't work that way
oh yeah dreaming yeah yeah yeah
Spider-Man
whenever the Eldon ring DLC comes Zelda
really want to play Zelda
and what else oh man what's the uh
I'm somewhat interested in Starfield but
I'm not like
I'm not totally locked in on it yet you
know
I'm sort of like waiting to see
something that will really
oh yeah yeah Star Wars game that's right
yep that's gonna be the next thing we
play on stream once we get the platinum
and Hogwarts like I see that's gonna be
the next game I play over on Twitch
hahaha
I was in charge of w what would you want
in the Wizarding World oh my gosh that's
a huge question we talked about that a
little bit like in terms of the game I
feel like it's best to focus on the game
we talked about that a little bit
tonight amazing cjb
but guys I mean hey that was perfect
timing right when the video ended I
think that's gonna be it dude I think
that's gonna be our spot to end tonight
I've got a long day ahead of me
very long day ahead of me we'll see how
the kids feel in the morning if they are
able to go to school or not
we'll see
because they've got a uh cough virus now
not not the virus but a a virus
so they got some medicine today and as
long they haven't had fever in a while
so as long as they feel okay they should
be able to go to school yeah so I gotta
I got an early start we'll try to be
live over on Twitch about 9 30. am
eastern time as we
it'll be a really quick stream and I
have like a hard out because I'll have
I'll go pick up my son
after about two hour two and a half
hours or so
it's Slytherin better as the first
playthrough better than
I mean honestly like
I would just go unless
Hufflepuff is the only one that I feel
like has a slight bump above the others
because of something that happens with
their story
that's it
and it's it's just one it's just
literally one mission
so like if you were on the fence with
Hufflepuff and something else I'd go
Hufflepuff but anything else
I think you're good with you're good
with whichever one yeah
you're good with either one
you know what you should take you take a
look at the house Relic robes
house The Relic house uniforms is how
they're actually described I think in
the game see which one you like best you
could pick by that
yeah EP we've been doing a lot of
streams over on Twitch
actually got raided by avalanche on
Friday we went from about
8 P.M to 3 A.M streaming and today we
started at 10 and ended after five so
we've been doing some big streams over
there as we try to uh make our way
through Hogwarts Legacy 100 percent
100 the game but guys man thank you so
much for being here it's been a blast
hope you all are having a great time
with the game those of you who haven't
started it yet you're in for a treat you
were in or a treat thanks again to WB
for hooking us up if you guys weren't
here at the beginning
let me show everybody real quick before
we sign off
you guys have already seen the
collector's edition
but they also sent us
this was really cool
these patches right here
[Music]
I'm gonna these are going
those are getting displayed somewhere
I don't know where but they're getting
displayed and then also the art book
but what this means is that I'm gonna be
doing a giveaway for my collector's
edition that I have not opened yet
here's the art book
I gotta open that up too
I actually look through it man haven't
even had the time to look through it you
know
so if anybody from WB watches thank you
so much again really appreciate it
awesome awesome gesture of you to send
that out really appreciate it epic outro
right you like that
oh and the music oh I feel like it's
just
it's leading us out dude
[Music]
don't unwrap it Mr cult the art book oh
you don't want me to look at it
Christy goodbye
oh my goodness all right guys it's been
fun have a good one replay Squad thanks
for the support let me know in the
comments as always thank you all so much
for watching
I'll talk to you again soon